Josh is Jacob going to be funnier than
you I'm GNA tell you this I hope so me
too I hope so but but I
think as a parent I want every aspect of
my kids lives to be better than mine was
I want I want him to
be
uh better at things than I am I I I
don't I can't imagine as a parent
wanting to be better than your kids like
I want whatever I have whatever I do
whatever I know I want all of my kids to
surpass that that's the [__] goal so
I of course I want him to be funnier
than you me he's probably not gonna be
let's be honest you who knows uh but I'm
kidding I will tell you this you off to
a [__] much quicker start than I was
dude well yeah but I had a foot in the
door so that doesn't matter foot in the
door doesn't matter dude I was getting
on stage no but I also mean foot in the
door as and I have you who also knows
the stories who also can help me think
of certain things like the set that I
have is is 100% me but also not you know
what I'm saying because you and I dove
into those stories and and worked on
tags and punchlines and story lines
together so but but we all we all sat
around in with each other and and and
pitched and did all that [__] all I'm
saying is that and again I'm not I'm not
like taking away from the work I've put
in I'm just saying I do have a little
bit of an upper hand because not only do
I have somebody who is funny giving me
tags but he knows the stories yeah he
knows what happened and he knows what we
can add or what we can take out for
commed Value yeah that's why you you
know what else dude you you already
don't have like I can give you notes and
you don't get offended why would I get
offended I'm six months in yeah yeah
yeah if I was 20 years in and you were
giving me notes I'd be like yo shut the
[__] up like I am 20 years in and you
get you're six months in and you gave me
a tag that worked that's true yeah for
me dude this ego is where just with
almost everything is where you get in
trouble and for me best idea wins and if
you at six months in have thought of a
better punchline than I've got and you
give it to me and I don't use it just
out of principle that's [__] dumb
yeah yeah that's dumb absolutely but is
Jacob gonna be funnier than me I hope so
I really do I'm I've said it a million
times but you have gotten real good real
quick so I'm excited to see where it
goes